c'est un travestissement de notre
sentiment d'impuissance cette
juridiction d'exception ciel si elle
était appliquée parce qu'en fait les
intelligents ont réussi à réchapper
et ils sont comme vous le disiez dans la
nature aujourd'hui les courageux sont
morts donc c'est une mascarade ceux qui
sont là qui reviennent on voit que c'est
des femmes des enfants des familles et
on dit le procureur de paris d'ailleurs
disaient qu'ils s'étaient plus des déçus
que des repentis donc en effet ils sont
ils sont encore dans leur idéologie sont
pas encore de pareils ça veut dire
attention attention on va pas les lâcher
dans la nature comme ça ruine sont pas
repentis et sont déçus mais mais de quoi
parle-t-on parce que maintenant cela dit
et je suis sceptique à ce qu'il dit je
suis pas du medef
il a dit je ne sens pas chez ace un
véritable ogre aux morts même de cet
engagement
mais en même temps en même temps c'est
une mascarade parce que n'importe va
venir c'est jihad islam est évidemment
on va les mettre dans une juridiction
d'exception c'est guantanamo enfin cdd
c'est toujours ça a produit des
résultats qui sont totalement négatif
qui ne sont pas les bons de quoi en fait
on n'a jamais trouvé encore la solution
pour traiter ces personnalités là pour
les rééduquer tous ces centres de
rééducation afin de d d islamisation de
déradicalisation 11e
on servira donc en fait on n'a pas
encore la solution mais on est dans ces
deux d'entre eux deux et vous avez tout
à fait raison de dire que ce serait un
aveu de faiblesse de que de les
soumettre à une juridiction d'exception
moi je suis totalement contre un plus je
crois profondément que tout homme peut
se re mettre dans une autre dynamique
donc je suis sûr que la rédemption est
possible que tout est possible donc
hall est tué sur place radical mais je
pense que concrètement une juridiction
d'exception en tout cas elle n'est pas
du tout à l'ordre du jour et n'est pas
souhaitable